les jours de semaine la maison des arts
de laval reçoit des écoliers chaque
année seize mille enfants viennent au
théâtre et faire des ateliers d'art mais
pas cette année on constate ici les
effets des moyens de pression des
enseignants pour en avoir discuté avec
des collègues d'autres salles de
spectacle c'est vraiment généralisée
tout le monde est à peu près à 30% ses
réservations habituels donc perte de 70
ironiquement les familles touchées par
la grève ont sauvé le spectale pourquoi
vous avez choisi le thé à assas et m'a
fait moi je connais passage au bio aux
hommes
les comédiens ont pu jouer plutôt que
chômer
à quelques rues de là les c'est ce qui
explique pourquoi ils se limitent
désormais alors semaine de 32 heures
on sait que les sorties ça déborde
beaucoup à l'extérieur des heures de
cours et/ou donc ce qu'on veut c'est que
les gens se rendent compte du travail
que sa demande de préparer une sortie si
les directions d'école reconnaissait ce
temps là les activités culturelles se
tiendrait le planétarium est désert les
groupes scolaires boudou si le biodôme
et l'insectarium
les trois institutions accuse une baisse
de plus de 50% depuis le 1er septembre
le musée des beaux-arts accueilli deux
fois moins d'élèves que les automnes
précédents la baisse est encore plus
importante pour le musée mccord une
baisse aussi à la maison t1 observons
une baisse de 34% chez nous donc ça fait
que ya moins de représentations et moins
d'élèves qui vont être en contact avec
du théâtre professionnel
maintenant on est solidaire de ce que
les enseignants et c'est de dire au
gouvernement mais il reste pour
l'instant dans le milieu culturel est un
peu pris en sandwich dans l'histoire ces
moyens de pression hantent même le
jardin botanique le nombre de
citrouilles décorées par les élèves a
diminué du cac
ici à nourrice despatie radio-canada
mourir